welcome to the show the big news over
the last 24 hours
three guilty verdicts in the killing of
george floyd by
former police officer derek shovin we
covered it all
live yesterday the verdict coming right
around uh
5 pm eastern time 4 p.m local time
central time in minnesota 10 hours of
jury deliberations before
three out of three guilty verdicts i was
not expecting this
um second degree murder guilty
third-degree murder guilty and
second-degree
manslaughter guilty let's go to the
reading of the verdict
by the court
all right please be seated
members of the jury i understand you
have a verdict
members of the jury i will now read the
verdicts as they will appear in the
permanent records of the fourth judicial
district
state of minnesota county of hennepin
district court fourth judicial district
state of minnesota plaintiff
versus derrick michael chauvin defendant
count one court file number 27 cr20126
we the jury in the above entitled matter
has to count one
unintentional second-degree murder while
committing a felony find the defendant
guilty
this verdict agreed to this 20th day of
april 2021 at 1
44 pm signed juror 4 person
juror number 19
same caption verdict count two we the
during the above entitled matter as to
count two
third degree murder perpetrating an
eminently dangerous act find the
defendant guilty
this verdict agreed to this 20th day of
april 2021
at 1 45 pm signed by jury four person
juror number 19. same caption
verdict count three we the jury in the
above entitled matter has to count three
second degree manslaughter culpable
negligence creating an unreasonable risk
find the defendant guilty this verdict
agreed to this 20th day of april 2021
at 1 45 pm okay and then
immediately uh the prosecution asking
for derek chovin to be handcuffed and
taken into custody pending sentencing
which we will talk about which will be
about eight weeks from now here is
derrick chauvin
let out of court in handcuffs is there a
motion on behalf of the state
would move to have the court revoke the
defendant's bail and remain him into
custody
pending sentencing bail is revoked bond
is discharged and the defendant is
remanded to the custody of the hennepin
county sheriff
anything further all right thank you
we're adjourned
so many different things to talk about
here
immediately of course is the question of
sentencing and
we have eight weeks until sentencing and
so we'll have more time
uh to talk about that but
the most serious of the charges
uh second-degree murder potentially
coming with up to
12 and a half years according to the
minnesota
sentencing guidelines um the prosecution
has asked for a longer
sentence saying there were kids present
at the scene
what derek chauvin did represented
particular cruelty
and that it included an abuse of
chauvin's position
of authority chauvin is 45 years old and
the sentencing will take place in eight
weeks and we will see
you there there's the possibility in
total of what would be
theoretically close to a life sentence
for derek chovin
or not and although one can make the
case
that his lawyer eric nelson failed here
to secure
even one not guilty verdict on any of
the of the
uh charges um with the chocolate chip
cookie closing statement and all of this
other stuff
uh the future of derek chauvin's life
may well actually be
in the sentencing and there will be time
for that the let's talk about the
implication of these verdicts though
um is this the start of a change to the
perception
of what police officers can get away
with this is not a happy moment you know
it's not
fun for people to go to prison for
killing others
it would be better if george floyd were
alive and
there were many right wingers talking
about oh the left is
happy now the left is thrilled about
what's going on it's a celebration
it's not a celebration that someone now
goes to prison
it it's the re recogn the the
recognition i guess i would say
that given the circumstances there will
be something approximating
accountability it's not even really
justice because
george floyd is dead and that's
irreversible
uh but we're going to talk about you
know in in a moment
there's also the realization that
this is a weird situation where the
state
of minnesota was prosecuting someone
that the state trained in essence now i
know
you know local police departments do
their own training but it's under the
guidance and under the framework of the
state of minnesota so
the state by prosecuting chauvin is in a
sense dealing with a problem
it created as part of a policing culture
that they have a role
in and now i understand literally in a
literal sense
the prosecutors aren't involved in
police training but it's the idea of the
state and the state
here uh involved on both ends and
there's
also the statistical reality that
officers who kill people
tend to avoid prosecution or if they're
prosecuted they tend to be acquitted
since 2005 out of 140 cases of police
being arrested and charged with murder
or manslaughter
as a result of an on-duty shooting out
of the 140 cases
97 have concluded the other 43 are still
pending so we can't say but of the 97
that concluded
there were seven murder convictions so
um when you understand that there's a
question
here of is this possibly the start to a
change
in the culture around what happens
in these cases um often they get reduced
to lesser offenses you have dismissals
and then of course you also have
acquittals and plea deals and different
things
so that is the result i did not expect
three guilty verdicts
i think i was probably leaning on kind
of a mixed verdict of some
not guilty and some guilty guilty on all
three
eight weeks until sentencing and the
next question
is what if anything does this say
about racism bigger picture let's talk
about that next
bernie sanders almost immediately after
the derrick chauvin verdict again
three guilty counts potentially decades
in prison
sentencing in eight weeks bernie sanders
using similar language to that which
many are are using and many of
our viewers used on the live stream
where we covered the verdict
that the chauvin verdict is
accountability
but it is not justice and it does not
fix issues
of systemic racism in the united states
bernie sanders sending a few tweets
let's look at them saying quote the
jury's verdict delivers accountability
for derek chovin
but not justice for george floyd real
justice for him and too many others can
only happen when we build a nation
that fundamentally respects the human
dignity of every person
bernie going on to say the trauma and
tragedy of george floyd's murder
must never leave us it was a
manifestation of a system that callously
devalues
the lives of black people finally
bernie's saying
our struggle now is about justice not
justice on paper
but real justice in which all americans
live their lives
free of oppression we must boldly root
out the cancer of systemic racism
and police violence against people of
color
so certainly this is a step forward
if it is a new era of
more police understanding that
they are in a position as uh
police officers that can be dangerous
for them there's no denying that
they are in a position where they are
put into situations that are by
their nature difficult and that require
exercising
judgment about what is the risk to them
and to others of the individuals that
they encounter but
the sort of free pass or close
to free pass that it's not my opinion
that statistically there has been
understand over the last decade and a
half
as i mentioned earlier out of 140 cases
of charges against officers
for murder or manslaughter of the 97
cases that have been resolved
seven guilty verdicts okay that this may
be a change
in terms of what they can get away with
and much like when barack obama was
elected president
it didn't end racism in fact
it arguably coalesced racism and
xenophobia
and subsequently led to donald trump
understand the backwards nature of that
this is potentially a step forward but
pervasive ignorance is not going
anywhere
anytime soon it is maybe the start it is
maybe a glimmer of hope it would be
great if it were true
uh that this was some major resolution
to america's problems but it's not and
and
again i want to repeat something that i
mentioned in the first segment about the
verdict
it is an odd situation where you have
the state of minnesota saying we are
going to deal
with what we believe is a wrong that was
committed right the state's saying
from what we saw we we are charging
derek chovan and we are prosecuting
derek chauvin
but derek chauvin is at least in a sense
a consequence of the policing system
overseen by that very same state of
minnesota and you could make a similar
analogy to other states
around the country different states
dealing with with issues of police force
to different uh degrees so um
we are now going to have to see what it
what is next
uh president joe biden speaking last
night
uh alongside kamala harris and others
and saying we we now have a problem that
hopefully we can start to deal with and
the question of how is it going to be
dealt with and to what degree
and will police departments play a role
as part of the solution or not and of
course police departments aren't
one thing and there are dramatically
different police departments in the
united states
uh to just as a reminder disclaimer i
know people get mad when i do this
i am not an abolish the police guy i am
a reformed the police guy
and i have extensive clips on our
youtube channel about why
that's my framework this is not you know
i know that there were some
who reacted to this by saying all cops
or bastards
abolish the police this guilty verdict
proves we get rid of police
go talk to them if you want to figure
out why they think that that's not my
view
i've made clear you know my eight to ten
point plan of uh police reforms that
that i would put in place so the
question i have for you and you can let
me know find me on twitter at d pacman
or elsewhere
um what do you hope this verdict means
and what do you think it most likely
means if anything bigger picture all
right find me on twitter
deepakman we'll take a quick break and
we will have extensive reaction
from all sorts of different people to
these three guilty verdicts that we got
yesterday
the number one funding source for the
david pakman show
has been and continues to be membership
and membership is not just a feel-good
thing you get access to the world famous
bonus show
every single day just for members as
well as commercial free
audio and video feeds of the show
day in and day out you can sign up for
membership
very very quickly at joinpackman.com
that's
join pakman.com
if the normal prices strike you as high
by
all means use the coupon code better21
all one word all lowercase become a
member today
the david pakman show has no money tree
from which we can collect
coins and dollar bills but we do have
some really great people
in our audience who support us through
our website membership program
you can sign up at joinpackman.com for
some reason that i cannot fathom
tucker carlson invited candice owens to
analyze and interpret the three guilty
verdicts
uh for former police officer derek
shovin who of course killed george floyd
last year yesterday we covered live
those three guilty verdicts and what's
funny about this
is that candace owens has no idea about
anything
it's not clear to me why she comments
about anything never mind
jury trials owens has become sort of a
conservative darling in some circles as
a
i guess former liberal who found
conservatism and of course being a black
woman even though the right is against
identity politics
being a black woman gives her a
particularly useful identity to the
american
right wing but watching her melt down
and just grasp at straws is both
entertaining but it's also a reminder
that tons of people will see
this they will see uh what candace owens
what you are about to see from candace
owens
and because they are unable to think for
themselves they will
accept it hook line and sinker and
that's a very dangerous reality
let's take a look at the first clip
kennesawans you'd think in a country
like ours very top i mean this is the
most first world country that's ever
been
you think the most civilized and the
most just
here you have to consider a murder case
through the lens of politics when you
get to that point haven't you already
given up civilization that's correct and
what we're really seeing is mob justice
and and that's really what happened with
this entire trial this was not a trial
about george floyd or derek chovin
this was a trial about whether the media
was powerful enough to create a
simulation and decide upon a narrative
absent any facts
it's almost like she didn't watch the
trial where fact
after fact after medical fact and
documentary evidence
were introduced mob justice what is she
talking about
and she gets even more divorced from
reality the longer she's allowed to keep
speaking and answering the same question
whether it was powerful enough to repeat
showing and talking about
a nine-minute clip that came from
somebody's cell phone without adding any
contacts without showing the full
you know the full police video which
they could have released they refused to
release the full body cam which
would have added more clarity now this
is sort of slippery
she throws in that the video of george
floyd being killed is from a cell phone
so what what difference does it make
that is from a cell phone
rather than cctv footage rather than 4k
or whatever and then she gish gallops
right into the
body cam footage wasn't even revealed
the absence of
body cam footage doesn't change this
from a guilty verdict into a not guilty
verdict
it's possible that if the body cam
footage was released
it might have shown something different
or it might have shown the same thing
probably the same thing based on the
sort of clear-cut nature of the video we
do have
but the absence of a video doesn't
actually make the verdict
wrong and it doesn't make it mob justice
and more importantly with how frequently
body cam footage
is quote lost or unavailable due to
technical problems if there were no cell
phone video
for all we know there'd be no video at
all
and we'd have zero accountability it is
rare that you actually have such an
incident
where there are witnesses and video when
you were talking about the death of
someone
understand that you know the vast
majority of homicides
um there's just no video and and cases
don't have
the documentary evidence that that we
had here okay let's watch one more clip
um to the fact that the media was lying
you know the media came out let's not
forget this tucker the media came out
and told us
that this was a man who was just getting
his life together he was a good
you know good member of society and he
got mixed up because
a racist white police officer had it out
for him and
killed him all of that fell apart those
actually are not
statements that really have anything to
do with the trial
you had jury selection derek chovin's
attorney had
every opportunity to strike jurors
potential jurors
if he felt that they had prejudged the
case
that they already believed that derek
chovin was guilty or whatever
there was a fair jury selection process
floyd turning his life around or not
is not actually relevant to the case
she is completely off the rails uh let's
actually watch a little bit more here
all the facts came out and all of that
fell apart we now know of course
that he had enough fentanyl in him it
was three times the lethal dosage three
times lethal to him when he died but
nobody cares
doctors testified very specifically
during the trial
george floyd did not die of a fentanyl
overdose
this is trash it is nonsense but
people are already repeating this stuff
on twitter and elsewhere
one more clip because the media was
successful and putting out a narrative
and they kept hitting that narrative and
the reason why democrats are happy is
because they realize of course
the media supports them and now means
the democrats can get whatever they want
because they can create a narrative and
then they can treat people like pawns
and get them to basically say
if we don't get what we want we will
riot
we will loot we will send these people
out like soldiers to destroy
your neighborhoods and that is exactly
what has happened that has been the
determination
of this trial the media and the
democrats now have enough power
to bully to bully and to lie to and to
create propaganda
and to successfully win and that is what
happened and they are celebrating that
win today
this was not a fair choice no person can
say this was a fair trial
she's just completely out of control and
who is she to say if the trial was fair
there was jury selection and both sides
had a chance to weigh in on jurors they
accepted the slate of jurors
the judge is there they will get a
chance to appeal if they want but she
just decided that this is not a fair
trial
it's actually a tragedy that candace
owens is interviewed as some kind of
expert i guess on what i don't know
democrats are happy
this is the sort of don jr liberals want
people to die of covid
to hurt trump thing no one's happy about
this i don't take joy at people going to
prison i'm against
imprisoning people uh as a sort of
general principle
it's horrifying that this trial even had
to take place
i would rather uh derek chauvin
uh be a a good police officer and george
floyd be alive
but george floyd is not alive and
accountability is necessary
but what i do enjoy is the right wing
melting down over this verdict and we're
going to look at some more examples uh
momentarily
so uh one of the things that will often
happen when there is uh what we would
call
sort of like a um saturation coverage
story
where with the verdicts yesterday in the
derek chauvin case
basically every news channel was
covering it live
right wing media essentially has no
choice but to cover it there's lots of
stories that right-wing media will just
ignore
but when you have like a saturation
story typically right-wing media has to
cover it
and often that leads to completely
unhinged meltdowns and lots of really
funny things so let's go through a few
things that happened yesterday in the
hours following
the three guilty verdicts uh for derek
chauvin in the killing of george floyd
here is greg gutfeld i guess now he's a
comedy host he
i guess he's a comedian i don't know he
has a comedy show now on fox news
he seemed to almost completely become
unglued
when a fox news guest called out gutfeld
for his
comments on the verdict take a look at
this now i gotta tell you
i heard uh greg a few minutes ago and i
gotta tell you i don't know greg
uh is off his meds if he believes excuse
me
was not excuse me
if you do not believe that there was
evidence
to support these charges i got a bridge
in brooklyn to scare you
isn't that something just everybody
losing their minds yesterday on
right-wing media
uh here is a daily wire host saying
and it's just so weird because these are
supposedly the due process and law and
order people
here's a daily wire host saying the only
verdict we could have trusted would be
not guilty
um anything else is not trustworthy what
take a look hours after the judge in the
case
reprimanded maxine waters who flew from
dc
to the city before the jury had started
deliberating to demand
a certain a guilty verdict in fact she
demanded a verdict on premeditated
murder which he wasn't even charged with
and first of all that whole maxine
waters going to to
minneapolis what else could that be
other than an attempt to intimidate and
tamper with the jury what other
motivation could you have
to fly as a high-ranking politician to
the city where this local murder trial
is happening
and demand that the jury come to a
verdict either you believe in fair
trials
or you don't either you want the jury to
weigh the evidence and come to a
decision or you don't it's clear that
they don't hear the problem
the irony is that the only verdict we
could really trust
is an acquittal in all accounts i think
that's would have been the right verdict
but
it's also the only one you can trust
because it's the only one that couldn't
have been motivated by anything
but um a look at the evidence
he says a look at the evidence could
only lead to not guilty
by this is like a no true scotsman
fallacy
guilt by definition according to this
guy means the jury did not look at the
evidence what happened to these people
what happened to due process and
respecting the process we have for
jury selection and a judge deciding what
evidence is admissible and is not
what happened um it's almost like they
really never believed it they just would
would go with it if it helped them this
next one's really good is ben shapiro
ben shapiro after the verdict says by
the way is there any evidence that this
was a racial killing and of course what
does that have to do with the charges
it has nothing to do with the charges
take a look both of those speeches were
about
how america is racist again
where is the racial component of where
is that is that that's enough where is
it like
has anyone yet provided the shred of
evidence to suggest that it was racial
killing i wasn't even you know
and then not only that you have joe
biden out there saying that america's
police all of our systems are actually
systemically racist
the guilty verdicts are for charges that
do not mention
race they were based on the facts of
the case here's one more candace owens
clip
we looked at her appearance with tucker
earlier here's candace owens hanging out
with the daily wire
guys pointing out that really
this is about george floyd being a drug
addict
take a look at this this is literally a
drug addict
okay he was a drug addict he abused
women he abused men he
you know this is this is disgusting that
that is it actually grosses me out
do we have no better examples to put
forward in the black community when you
think of the word justice
you think of george floyd i mean how far
we have fallen since martin luther king
just grasping at straws they have no
idea what to do with themselves
going now from fox news and daily wire
to newsmax
here is a news max host saying that the
jury
sacrificed derek chovin to the mob
yeah no it's it it's pressure on the
scale right i mean this they say justice
is blind i don't think
it was blind in this case at all i think
you had political pressure i think you
had pressure from all these uh
activist groups uh going into all this
and i think at the end of the day
people say you know what if we acquit
this guy this city is going to burn
to the ground it is going to burn to the
ground so you had a jury that said you
know what
we're going to have to sacrifice this
guy to the mob and that's exactly what i
think happened today
this was not according to this newsmax
host jurors
looking at the evidence and deciding
guilty or not guilty
it was jurors sacrificing derek chauvin
to the mob immediately after the guilty
verdict
newsmax host also saying it was not a
fair trial what what happens tonight we
don't know i mean obviously right now
it's still light outside there's a lot
of security around there you've got
a group of people i would assume that's
some members of
the family of floyd or friends of floyd
they're celebrating
we don't know what this turns into it's
nightfalls again there's
sometimes there's no appeasing a mob in
a situation like that we don't we have
three
guilty counts the first thing that i
thought of in my head was
you know and we talked a lot about this
with uh with dershowitz uh alan
dershowitz
uh how on earth uh was he expecting to
get a
fair trial in this thing there was a
tremendous amount of pressure
on that jury i mean you would have had
to have been out of your mind
to vote to acquit this man knowing full
well
that everybody is going to figure out
who you are and you're going to have the
likes of blm antifa protesters coming
after you with everything they got if
you're the one person that says oh no
i i think he was innocent i think george
floyd probably ate a pocket full of
drugs when the cops came up to him he
had a bad heart they put him on the
ground
if he hadn't done those things he might
have had a stiff neck the next day but
he died instead
i like how it's totally peaceful but he
still has to say well you know
it's light out right now it'll probably
get really dangerous when it's dark out
and of course it didn't and of course
the things that the host is proposing
were debunked in the trial by medical
experts so
yes it's pathetic and um it is
unfortunate that so many people are
already repeating these lines
with absolutely no critical thinking
applied whatsoever
and there is one more that i'm going to
play for you
after the break because it actually
deserves its own segment it is tucker
carlson
appearing to have a psychotic break and
kicking his guest off air when talking
about the verdict so
right after this short break we'll jump
into that and we will have more of these
clips
on our instagram page you can find us on
instagram
at david pakman show the david pakman
show is audience
supported media and you can contribute
any amount you want on patreon as little
as one dollar per month
plus you can get the daily bonus show
world famous at this point
and the daily commercial free tv show
by making those pledges at patreon.com
slash david pakman show this is audience
supported media we depend on the support
of our viewers and listeners
whether you listen to the podcast watch
on youtube or watch us on tv
or even listen on the radio patreon.com
david pakman show this is one of the
strangest clips uh from right-wing media
from the reaction to the derek chauvin
verdict uh tucker carlson had an
apparent psychotic break during a
segment last night with a former
new york city corrections officer during
which tucker started
maniacally laughing in a way that was
reminiscent of jack nicholson's joker
from the batman movie
and then abruptly ended the segment and
kicked the guest off of his show
and much of what tucker does on his
program in general
appears to be acting and fox news
lawyers have even said tucker does
entertainment he's not
like literal news but something about
this segment
strikes me as the real tucker tucker
seemingly unhinged
let's take a look at the clip tucker's
interviewing at gavin former new york
city corrections officer
the former corrections officer said
listen derek shoven used
excessive force on george floyd tucker
carlson just loses it look at this
the scene i i just think that it was
excessive and it shouldn't happen
and what i'd like to do the guy who did
it looks like he's going to spend the
rest of his life in prison so
i'm kind of more worried about the rest
of the country which thanks to police in
action in case you haven't noticed is
like
boarded up so that's more of my concern
but i appreciate you coming on ed gavin
thank you
nope done thank you isn't that something
if you thought that the matt gates
interview was weird two three weeks ago
because of gates's behavior
it was nothing compared to tucker's
behavior last night
what do you think this is about like is
it is this that tucker maybe
senses that the chauvin verdict is part
of
their grip slipping away and maybe a new
era of accountability being ushered in
that would be great
i don't think that's actually why tucker
is behaving like this
was tucker planning on running video of
violent riots from minnesota last night
and there were no violent riots so this
is what he came up with instead
one cop found guilty and tucker is
instantly off his rocker it's very
weird and the laugh is particularly
unsettling but also kicking the guest
off when you supposedly run a show
that's about discussing
ideas even when your ideas might
conflict with somebody else's it's bad
enough
and of course this gets us back to the
really consequential piece of all of
this which is that there are
so many people who watch tucker
and they take him seriously and they
take his show seriously and they take
his perspective
seriously you and i might see this and
say
first of all how can anyone watch this
and react by saying
wow this seems like a good place to take
my my opinions from
but there are people who will react and
not think that that's a completely
unhinged person and for many people
sadly shows like tucker carlson's are
the only
input that they receive to form their
view
of what's going on in the world and in
the united states and that's a really
scary thing
now one one other note this isn't the
only time that tucker has sort of broken
like this
there was that incident it feels like it
was maybe a year and a half to two years
ago
when dutch historian rutger bregman
who's been a guest on this show you can
check out my interview with rucker on
our youtube channel rutger bregman was
interviewed by tucker
tucker didn't like the direction the
interview was going rutger
was clearly not laying down for tucker
carlson
tucker went nuts attacking rutger
bregman
swearing at him and then refused to air
the interview
we only found out about it because
fortunately there was a recording that
was released
so we were able to see it but between
that
and tucker's reportedly losing it at his
own country club on an employee or some
other guest
you can look that story up my sense is
that the 20 seconds i played for you
here
of tucker both furious with his guests
and
laughing maniacally in a way that seems
completely divorced from from reality
that i believe is the real tucker that i
think is the closest we get to the real
tucker because it matches the tucker
that we saw in what tucker hoped would
be an unaired interview with rutger
bregman
and it's the same tucker that is
described in his country club outburst
um i think that's the real tucker let me
know what you think
we have stumbled across another possible
major scam from the donald trump
administration
it turns out that the trump
administration
gave a 1.3 billion dollar contract to a
company called
apiject like inject but a
app or maybe it's even api checked like
a
uh a like a computer api they gave him
uh
he gave them a 1.3 billion dollar
contract to make
covid vaccine syringes the u.s has now
given out about
close to 200 million individual doses
and there are
zero vaccine syringes from a
appy jack to ap jacked api eject
what the hell is going on we don't know
uh nbc news reporting that a year
after the company was awarded an almost
1.3 billion dollar
uh contract uh and loan package
to supply syringes for rolling out the
covet 19 vaccine
zero syringes have been made
the syringe hasn't even gotten the first
approval it needs from the fda before it
can be manufactured
and the factory that was going to create
650 jobs to create this as yet
unapproved vaccine
has not even been built 1.3 billion
contracts and loans
no factory no approval
no syringes the company api
systems corporation said it was going to
be the company
that would make the difference between a
bad rollout
and a good rollout of the coronavirus
vaccines
thanks to the biden administration the
u.s coronavirus vaccine rollout is going
really well uh about half of american
adults have received at least
one dose we are close uh we are rapidly
uh getting into the 30s and soon 40s in
terms of the percentage of americans
that have been fully vaccinated
the need for this syringe from api
eject is now drastically diminished
because we basically have
what we need and it seems as though we
are going to have everything we need to
fully vaccinate the united states
and yet the contracts and the loans are
still there
uh api eject was contacted by nbc news
they were asked
what the hell is going on that was not
how the question was asked that's how i
would ask it
they said that they are quote working
with several pharmaceutical companies to
conduct
testing and reviews of the api eject
syringe for covid19 vaccination what
when is this going to happen it's going
to be over before they make any vaccine
syringes
a spokesperson from pfizer
said that even if the api eject syringe
was approved by the fda it would have
no impact on the level of vaccine output
or on the process for distributing
vaccines
by pfizer moderna was asked what about
you they didn't respond
johnson and johnson uh declined to
comment on this
what a it's just listen we don't yet
know the full scope of this
there should be audits of every single
one of these contracts that the trump
administration
gave out if the recipients aren't at a
stage
in the process that they should be or
close to actually being able to deliver
what they were contracted to do
the contracts which i mean do they need
to be canceled
the government should be asking for
money back should lawsuits be filed to
try to
recoup the money that's already been
paid because increasingly it seems that
there is no
uh economic policy
or uh contract or whatever you know any
it all during the trump administration
seems to
link to mostly unsuccessful uh
either outright failures or incompetency
or participating in grifting
by these companies there was another one
we covered a few months ago and i the
details
are just beyond my my uh recollection
but i think it was a ppe company
that was not even making the ppe but it
was like a middleman of some kind that
the trump administration gave a big
contract to
and they had like no employees they were
a three-month-old con it was just
all grifting grifting grifting um
api checked spokesperson steve hoffman
says when asked about the factory
because remember this was a contract and
loans
to do coveted vaccine syringes add a new
factory that would generate 650 jobs
the spokesperson for api jack steve
hoffman was asked by nbc news where's
the factory
and he says that land has been cleared
for construction in north carolina asked
when will the
actual construction begin steve hoffman
was not able to say
it seems likely that the land
is not good at the factory is not going
to be built in time
for api to participate in
syringe production that will be
materially relevant to the covid vaccine
distribution um it was all a grift it
was all a grift and
ev it's almost every week we find out if
some trump administration grift
or trump campaign grift related to
fundraising related to contracts
related to uh positions for friends and
family of donald trump it just
never stops i don't expect we will ever
know the full scope of it i'm hopeful
that over time we will learn
more and more about it i don't think we
are going to learn the full scope
let me know what you believe should be
done with these types of contracts
should api check have to return the
money
what exactly should happen or should we
take the approach of
it's in the past let's let them get away
with the 1.3 billion
i tend to think the answer is no to that
second option let me know what you think
we'll take a quick break i do want to
follow up about what's in it you know
the biggest beneficiary of the last 24
hours
48 hours 72 hours of coverage
of the derek chauvin case and other
things the biggest beneficiary
has been matt gates who has been able to
get
a respite from the focus on him
but he is still in full damage control
mode we're going to talk about that
after the break
and we are also hearing about a
republican
that supposedly is moving in the
direction of running for president in
2024.
i will tell you who it is and the
implications right after this short
break
the david pakman show is now on
instagram at david pakman show you can
check out
behind the scenes pictures memes
shots of the studio shots of what
pat does all day very very concerning to
a lot of people all of that and more on
the david pakman show
instagram account at david pakman show
as i mentioned before the break
one of the biggest beneficiaries of the
last 48 to 72 hours of the news cycle
being on the derek chauvin case
has been republican congressman matt
gates who
is in full full damage control mode
my he should be in resignation mode not
damage control mode
and uh i i believe that the attention is
going to get back to matt gates there's
a
very interesting daily beast article uh
which
points out that quote his latest
campaign finance report
reflects a public relations scramble
that began even before he acknowledged
being the focus of a federal
investigation we now are learning that
matt gates knew
much earlier that he was the focus of
this investigation and that he was
already working
on his public relations campaign the
filing which covers the three months
between january
and march writes the daily beast shows
that gates has incurred unprecedented
fundraising expenses during a typically
quiet period
in that time gates dropped six figures
on a direct mail blitz
shelling out more for fundraising
services than he did in all of 2020. now
understand the cycle
one of my criticisms of the status quo
of the house of representatives and
two-year terms is that with two-year
terms
you basically get elected you get six
months
and then you start campaigning again
matt gates
is doing the fundraising during that six
month period
where you are typically not campaigning
it's basically a year and a half of
campaigning not two
matt gates is starting right away and it
tells us
quite a bit about the panic that he is
likely feeling as a result of these
investigations uh the article goes on to
say gates also paid five thousand
dollars
in strategic consulting fees to
notorious political operative
roger stone and he gave money to a
number of republican florida state
lawmakers that he has never supported
before
what it appears he's trying to do there
and again we're left to read into the
actions of a madman
it seems he's trying to curry favor with
some of these fellow florida
republicans so that they will not
abandon him and hopefully will speak out
in his support
if and when it gets really really ugly
for him which could be any time
the daily beast writes that the report
also indicates gates
may be increasingly isolated he's
received no contributions from his
republican
colleagues more than anything the filing
reflects a concerted effort to bolster
support
ahead of the creeping shadow of the
investigation gates has spent roughly
170k
on direct mail this year 160 000 of it
all on one day march 31st
i think that's the day after i i know i
was on
our i was on our break that day that
must be the day after
the bizarre interview with tucker
carlson the previous day the new york
times broke the news that the justice
department was looking into whether he
had sex with a 17 year old and paid for
her travel
which possibly violates federal sex
trafficking
laws gates has also invested in
fundraising paying nevada-based redrock
strategies
nearly 160 k for fundraising consulting
that's more than he spent on fundraising
services
in 2019 and 2020 combined
that is stunning last week politico
reported gates spent six figures on tv
ads
punching back against the accusations 30
second spots slated to run
in his home district in the florida
panhandle and on national cable networks
asking supporters to quote fight back
against a quote multi-week fake news
cycle targeting cnn there is one expense
in particular raising eyebrows a five
thousand dollar strategic political
consulting fee to drake
ventures that's the company belonging to
roger stone
friday the department of justice sued
stone and his wife saying they owe
millions of dollars in unpaid taxes
and are using that very same drake
ventures
to shelter more than one million dollars
isn't that unbelievable look at look at
how
the tentacles of gates are spreading
into so many different things so there's
the investigation into gates
which we already talked about and then
now in light of that it's sort of weird
that gates was the lone no vote on some
sex trafficking bill a couple of years
ago or whatever okay that's weird and
we're starting to see that in a new
light
then we learn about gates's alleged
involvement
in a shill candidate scheme in a
different district
in the state of florida we had a report
on that i believe it was earlier mid
last week now we find out
that gates paid a consulting fee to
roger stone's company
and it is the very same company that now
allegedly is a way for roger stone and
his wife
to shelter more than a million dollars
and
uh avoid paying taxes it's so
tied in with all of this stuff and in a
sense i don't feel bad for him
but gates may end up being another sort
of victim
of the trump grift the way that the
trump grift works
is trump loves you loves you loves you
for as long as you
are saying good things about him and for
as long as you are useful to him and
trump will introduce you to all sorts of
different people who knows how matt
gates ended up
sort of entangled with roger stone in
the first place my instinct is that it
has something to do with donald trump
as soon as you were no longer useful to
trump or as soon as you were potentially
a problem
due to your own issues that you were
having from a public relations
standpoint
trump is gone and uh indeed
the reports are that matt gates has been
trying to meet with trump
uh matt gates has been claiming that he
has donald trump support although it's
not
completely clear that that's the case
and uh it
it is another in at least partially i'm
not saying gates
did the stuff if if gates did the stuff
he's accused of doing he didn't do it
because of donald trump
but he is another one of these guys who
got sort of lulled into trump's circle
as a brown-nosing
sycophant and then dropped like a bad
habit as soon as he was no longer useful
one other piece of this very extensive
daily beast article about what's going
on with matt gates
quote the report also suggests gates has
few friends in washington while gates
swore off donations from corporate pacs
he kept the door open to donations from
candidate committees
but he has so far reported no financial
support in 2021 from friends in congress
like jim jordan and steve scalise
both of whom donated back in 2020 while
gates made same-day 4 000 donations to
mike lee and rand paul
gates did not give money to any house
colleagues
he did send out a thousand a few five
one thousand dollar donations to five
republican florida senators
and had not donated to their campaigns
previously
so uh i would expect
that the media attention will go back to
matt gates
at some point relatively soon at some
point relatively soon i would imagine we
will know whether there will be charges
filed as a result of what appear to be
multiple investigations into
matt gates uh but certainly gates must
be thrilled
that for the last two to three days the
focus has been not on him but rather
on derek chauvin we'll get back to him
no question about it
uh on the friday show i am going to be
answering an
audience question about which
republicans are likely to get out of the
way if donald trump runs in 2024
versus which republicans are likely to
run against trump in 2024
uh the the the list of the latter is
probably relatively short
i think mitt romney would be someone
who's on the list even though i don't
think
romney plans to run romney is the type
of guy who
if he wants to run in 2024 he'll run
against trump in the republican primary
he won't step down
or step back or stand by because donald
trump may choose to run
the new report from axios is that chris
christie's friends believe he is gearing
up for a 2024
run axios writing that former new jersey
governor chris christie
is seriously considering running for
president in 2024
three people familiar with his thinking
tell axios
while christie isn't saying anything
publicly besides telling radio host hugh
hewitt that he's not ruling it out
people close to christy have a sense of
the rationale and outlines of a
candidacy the big picture is that absent
a run by trump
the field would be wide open christie
ran in 2016
didn't go well he told friends he'd be
the only person
in 2024 with executive experience
who's run a presidential race before i
guess that's
maybe true when you compare him to like
ted cruz ted cruz has run but he doesn't
have executive experience i guess that
sort of makes sense
but florida governor ron desantis
has executive experience for whatever
reason governorships are called
executive experience i guess it's
because they are more administrative in
a sense than for example being a member
of the house or a member of the u.s
senate
desantis as axios writes is experiencing
a surge of popularity from republicans
because he opened florida wide open very
early
but desantis has not yet been
scrutinized
by national media as a candidate and who
knows what might surface
from that axios writes that christie's
approach would be to run on his
reputation for being tough
and that that could appeal to the trump
base but he's not going to come off as
reckless the way donald trump came off
you know the entire uh george washington
bridge
closing down a lane as a political
uh punishment that seems pretty reckless
to me
but i guess when you're comparing the
recklessness of christie to the
recklessness of trump
he seems less reckless that's true axia
axios also writes that chris christie
may have crossover appeal
to blue-collar voters as well as
suburban
center-right voters that's possible and
also that his experience as a former
federal prosecutor
could distinguish him in debates and
prepare him for a primary
where um there may be more of a premium
placed on
sort of being buttoned up rather than
being unhinged like donald
trump i think that this is tough for
chris christie you know the the things
that he's known for
really in my mind are
um the the bridgegate fiasco
and supporting donald trump in
completely humiliating
fashion in 2016 and
neither of those are particularly
inspiring from my perspective
but listen maybe the republican primary
uh voters would would like it
christy didn't do well in 2016. i don't
know that he ever had more than like two
or three percent support but listen
things are different
and i think what is abundantly clear is
that christy is only a candidate
if trump does not run and uh
again we'll dig into that in more detail
on friday who might actually run against
trump because
christie's only a candidate if trump is
not ted cruz isn't going to run against
donald trump lindsey graham
forget about it lindsey graham i don't
think is running regardless but lindsey
graham is not going to run against
donald trump
nikki haley told us last week or was it
monday
that she if donald trump runs she won't
run
and she will support donald trump so uh
that
that is the the situation with uh chris
christie
i actually what's crazy is
if you said to me whoever wins the
republican
primary will be the president
chris christie is maybe the guy i lean
towards i mean if you say
chris christie or ted cruz will be the
next president i'm going with chris
christie
if you say chris christie or i don't
even know you know
rand paul will be the next president i'm
going with chris christie
uh he has i'm not praising him but
he has more centrist sensibilities
he actually seems competent
in a narrow way that donald trump is not
when you think about his experience as a
prosecutor and as a governor he did
horrible things as a governor
bridgegate is an immoral fiasco um
but i probably lean towards someone like
chris christie
more than just about anybody i can think
of that ran
in i mean kasich and again i'm not
saying these people are my ideal
candidates it's just if i knew that the
republican nominee would be the
president i'm leading towards someone
like maybe kasich or chris christie
despite having many many disagreements
with them so
let me know what you think about chris
christie's potential candidacy
we'll talk friday about who might
actually fight trump in the 2024
republican primary
if it were to come to that we have a
voicemail number that number is 2192
david p
um we have switched
live phone calls from a sort of normal
phone line to using discord
i think that the calls are much better
both in terms of audio quality and
in terms of substance but this caller
doesn't like it
he's almost like begging me for mercy to
stop the calls altogether take a listen
to this
oh my god no more
discord calls right
agonizing just make a separate show
if you want to hear from people all
around the world it's horrific
other than that i really like the show
thank you i appreciate the compliment
yeah listen i mean we've gone through
this before
most people like the calls the people
that don't
absolutely hate them we've packaged them
in the second half of the friday show
the rest of the entire week of shows is
not
live calls um and we're we're we are
looking at
you know different mechanisms maybe for
screening or different things i get it i
get that it's not for everybody but
we actually do get the calls that are
good i think are really good and the
audio quality has improved on discord
the substance has improved on discord so
we're going to keep it going for now but
it's very easy to skip it if you don't
like it okay
on the bonus show today we will talk
about democrats blocking a resolution to
censure
maxine waters over her comments
regarding
george floyd derek shove and verdict
protests i think her comments were
misguided
we will talk though about the absurdity
of the censure resolution
uh given what people in the republican
party have said
a u.s senators are looking to ban
private ownership of lions and tigers
this is actually part of a bigger story
which i will talk about
on the bonus show as well and we are
going to talk about
the completely abortive launch of
my pillow ceo mike lindell's social
media platform it was
a disastrous and humiliating fiasco
which i love it i'm not gonna lie i am
really enjoying the disaster
of the my pillow uh social media
platform launch
all of those stories and more
and i will be joined by producer pat on
today's bonus show
you can get the bonus show as a member
by signing up at joinpackman.com
i believe to this day that the normal
membership pricing
is very very reasonable but i am always
glad to offer you a discount you can use
the coupon code
immoral 21 yes immoral the discount is
so low
it's almost immoral immoral 21 all one
word all lowercase to get a big discount
off of membership and then you will get
instant access to the bonus show and i
will see you then or tomorrow
if you're not a member